distracted by a very beautiful woman in
red oh it's my wife the wife is here you
bring you you're having a date night for
the premiere yeah yeah great date night
no not the best date night right really
with your husband like having to talk to
a bunch of other people I guess it sucks
I'm just gonna have a lot of fun by
going back home and okay you've seen the
movie yes what was the face you made
when the credits roll I don't know
because I can't see my own face Oscar
you got a player theme I don't have like
the little antenna with the eyes looking
that way I have no idea what my face on
it okay what do you think you I don't I
know no I don't know okay well this saga
has been magical watching you guys
together what will you miss most about
working with my friends working with JJ
and the John and Daisy and Anthony in
particular I think the fact that we got
to work so closely on this one together
was really fun and yeah just working
with them going every day laughing as
much as we did just had such a good time
four years ago we were standing in this
very spot let's relive the moment do you
remember what you were thinking what you
were feeling I said I don't know who I'm
hugging but it feels good anyone who's
willing to hug I'm surprised this isn't
John I was very excited that night it
was a very excited yeah
not so much now I'm fully excited it's
crazy we've like reached the top of the
mountain and we're sighing a sigh of
relief and hopefully people feel happy
after they see the movie
[Music]